hello and Mazel Tov's it's your friends
at the Reno Sheriff's Department and
this year we're making real effort to
respect all cultures Oh even some of the
Asian stuff Reno Sheriff's Department
has always celebrated different in
diverse cultures as far as anyone knows
oh sure this outreach is not just part
of some lawsuit by those kids at the
ACLU and that limousine liberal like Tim
Robbins but a lot of folks wonder why
you Jewish New Year not the same as
white people new here it's a gosh-darn
conundrum when do I say Happy New Year
to jr. says names of Jewish Prince here
well the Jewish calendar operates on the
moon like witches for example today is
tuffet five thousand seven hundred and
seventy nine easier than you think once
you know this simple way to remember it
jump we all know the Jewish here is
called Rosh Hashanah or Yom Tahara and
it starts on the first day of Tishrei
and ends on the second day of Tishrei
which is the first month of the jewish
civil year but not on the first day of
the ecclesiastical year which is the
month of Nisan but don't panic you can
always tell what Jewish here it is
simply by adding one three thousand six
hundred and seventy one to the year it's
that easy
so happy New Year everybody and to our
Jewish friends
happy Monday night on the buns
you